[Musique]
cette semaine je vais vous parler du
film amor larbitre qui a été réalisé par
Jean-Pierre Mocky en 1984 avec comme
comédien principaux Eddy Mitchell et
Michel Serrault alors pourra vous
raconter un peu l'histoire du film donc
en fait c'est une course poursuite entre
des supporters d'une équipe de foot et
l'arbitre du match qui les arbitrer
juste avant
donc en fait ça se déroule sur une
soirée une nuit entière les supporters
vont courir après l'arbitre durant toute
la soirée il va y avoir des drames
durant cette soirée
je voulais parler de ce film parce que
je pense que Jean-Pierre Mocky est un
réalisateur dont on parle pas assez
c'est un réalisateur indépendant qui a
fait beaucoup de films en se
débrouillant par lui-même en trouvant
des financements trouvant des
producteurs et trouvant des comédiens
qui souvent jouaient bénévolement
ce film a pas rencontré un grand succès
en salle puisqu'il a fait peut-être
100000 100000 entrées au box-office mais
par la suite donc 20 ans après quand il
est passé à la télé il y a eu beaucoup
de personnes qui ont regardé ce film
notamment un journaliste de Libération
qui à l'époque à l'époque disait que ce
film était une satire vraiment flippante
et toujours d'actualité du fanatisme de
certains supporters donc voilà je vous
conseille d'aller le voir si vous n'avez
jamais vu de films de Jean-Pierre Mocky
je pense que c'est l'un des films
références de ce réalisateur
[Musique]